sorry i'm just i am a little nervous
i've thought a lot more about being a
dad than i thought about
um making conversation with the person
carrying my baby
right well i'm nervous too to my sperm
to the donor's egg and to your uterus
cheers cheers mom
dad i have some exciting news
i'm pregnant i mean the surrogate is
pregnant
i'm not going to tell anybody i'm matt
i just don't have anyone that i really
need to share the news with
does that bother you matt
[Music]
hey sorry hey man bryce so did you guys
just do it or
matt oh who is this guy you can't do
that it says hugh are you like her
uncle or something oh i'm not her uncle
i'm the father
oh my god you're your father no i'm not
her dad what do you think
it is more than fine to have sex when
you're pregnant but like my baby
is in there absorbing ejaculate i
use protection
[Music]
why are you doing this alone because i
am alone
i'm in this chapter of my life that
feels like it should be over but it's
not
it's just on a loop it's weird to be
perceived as hopeless in this moment
when i'm actually incredibly hopeful
why are you alone i don't think being
alone is a bad thing
so are you gonna have the baby shower i
just want to say thank you for
doing this with me and i also apologize
for everyone i know
is that what this is like like donating
an organ i don't know
i've never donated an organ before
we should have better boundaries are we
friends
aren't we i think that if we are
in order for this to work we shouldn't
be
i'd like to start class with a cleansing
breath
sometimes people just connect it's not
about being attracted to one another
so how many friends in their 20s do you
have
i don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
at some point you will give birth to a
child and then what happens
just because you're not like together
together doesn't mean that you haven't
created a bond
[Music]
but i'm really worried that you're
probably making a little straight white
guy in there
that's the whole plan i'm gonna
oh i just gave him a podcast
you